So, this is last year.
Jay Dyer said, "Cops are enraged. I was
skeptical of the ISIS videos 10 years
ago, but even the mainstream media
doubted them." The second article here
refers to the Washington Post. So, that
was back when he was saying he doubted
the the executions of the 21
Coptic Christians. Mhm.
>> And AP replied, he said, "Do you agree
the martyrs were actually beheaded?" So,
he's like, "Do you think it actually
happened now? Do you agree the martyrs
were actually beheaded?" And Jay says,
"I don't know what happened. I don't
call them martyrs any more than I call
Hezbollah leaders a martyr."
Wow. So, they're not martyrs because
they weren't martyred for the true
church, and they're basically in the
same category
as Hezbollah jihadis. He wouldn't call
them He wouldn't call those guys martyrs
because they're outside the church just
like these uh these Copts were. Mhm. And
then one one more here.
So, this is from Andrew Wilson, and I
I'm I want people to understand like
what these guys
actually believe about people outside
their church. So, this is a Andrew
Wilson. This is Andrew Wilson, and he's
got two memes there. So, the meme on the
left was one that was sent to him to
describe what's going on with the
Orthobros, and then he fixed it. So,
um I'll show you the actual memes here.
This is the first one that was sent to
him.
Okay. So, in this one,
an unbeliever is saying, "Help me. She's
on fire."
And a Christian runs up and says, "Don't
worry. Here comes the water of life."
So, this is uh this is meant to describe
preaching the gospel to the person,
everyone.
>> Mhm. Mhm. And then he finds out what the
and it's the hose isn't working.
And it's because an Orthobro has
has turned off
>> [laughter]
>> has turned off the hose, and he says,
"First, let's settle who the real
firefighter is between the two of us.
So, that's what people are saying right
now. We got We got Muslims People are
trying to evangelize Muslims and the
Orthodox goes, "No, you have to debate
us on the true church or you're not
allowed to do anything."
So, that was sent to That was posted to
um Andrew Wilson. Check out Andrew
Wilson's response. He said he fixed it.
He said he fixed He fixed the meme. So,
here's his meme.
It's an unbeliever An unbeliever is on
fire.
And then a fireman runs up and it you
see uh it's kind of small there, but the
fireman's hat says Protestant Christian.
Protestant Christian There's a
Protestant.
And the the Protestant Christian is
actually um trying to pour gasoline
trying to Right.
>> put out the fire with gasoline. And then
it's the Orthodox guy who unhooks it to
keep the Protestant Christian from
pouring gasoline on this person. Well,
what's that mean? It means that they
think we're actually doing evil when we
preach the gospel when we preach the
gospel to Muslims, we're actually
making the situation worse and doing
something that's completely evil. And
that's why they need to do what?
What's the meme say? You stop them from
preaching that you have to stop them
from preaching the gospel to Muslims.
Stop them from doing that.
So, guys, I don't know how I don't know
how else they can make it clear
that they believe anyone who's outside
of their church who's uh refuting Islam
um evangelizing Muslims, you're actually
doing harm and that's why you have to be
stopped. And that's why I guess what?
That's why they were they would have no
problem aligning with Dawah guys to stop
non-Orthodox Christians from preaching
the gospel. That's why they have no
problem being aligned on that issue.
Right.
>> We're We're We're all We're all outside
the church, so we're just making We're
just making things worse.